i focus on easy to understand concept
the food should be just tasty and i
focus on japanese fried chicken because
everybody loves it and everybody
understands it nothing is difficult
about it hi my name is kuniko yagi i'm
the owner chef of pikuniko downtown l.a
today i'm going to show you how to make
golden chicken sandwich and coleslaw key
for this recipe will be being patient
everything had to do with the different
textures pickles has their own vegetable
texture fried chicken should be crispy
but the bun is soft
i made piconico fried chicken as gluten
free because i do have a lot of friends
who is allergic to gluten or the wheat
and i wanted to make a wide range of
customers who can come to pikuniko best
part of
running small restaurants is that i get
to see an actual reaction from every
guest i have that's the best part of
being a chef i'm frying chicken one
piece at the time so that fried chicken
comes out crispy
while i'm using rice flour for the crust
you'll still get the same crunch as
american fried chicken typically
japanese fried chicken has no bones in
so it's easy to eat and also the
marinade that we use is asian
ingredients garlic ginger soy sauce
potato starch i brought my turmeric bun
from my restaurant today but you can
easily substitute with the high quality
hot dog bun and i recommend to toast
them a little bit
new menu inspiration always comes from
local farmers market or the weather but
since we run japanese fried chicken
restaurant i try to make everything
japanese version of something the
favorite part of making this sandwich is
actually assembling there are so many
ingredients and vegetables but once you
get it down it's not too difficult it
may be easy to find like ginger and
garlic and all that but if you don't
have white sesame paste it's equivalent
to tahini paste i'm whisking olive oil
into the other ingredients of sesame
vinaigrette to make it creamy because
sesame paste is full fat it'll be easy
for you to emulsify this in japan when
you eat fried food shredded cabbage or
julienned cabbage comes with it as a
free food and it's philosophy of
digestion the cabbage will help you to
digest the fried food the moment i
decided to have it on the menu i wanted
to make the best sandwich ever my recipe
is pretty simple and the hardest part is
shopping and correcting all the
ingredients but once you have it in the
kitchen it is very simple to make this
dishes so i hope you can do it at home
and feel like you're such a great chef
oh yes
[Music]
you